[Aplausos]
fechem os olhos por favor é rápido não
vou fazer mágica
tá fiquem tranquilos fechem os olhos por
favor é rápido
imagine um anjo do guarda essa imagem
um príncipe e uma princesa e uma boneca
guarda essas imagens e agora podem abrir
os olhos
eu quero saber se as imagens que vocês
conseguiram visualizar quantas delas são
negras
pois é eu confesso que até hoje eu faço
esse teste e ainda não consegui diz
construir essas imagens que a minha
mente insiste reproduzir
como desconstruir isso a pergunta que eu
faço é se o que você vê quando fecho os
olhos é um mundo que você quer é um do
que você imagina
eu quero saber se o que você enxerga
tá bom pra você tá bom pra você é bom às
vezes eu acho que parece que tem alguém
que domina o que eu penso
controla qual como devo me comportar
como eu devo vestir que cabelo devo usar
parece até uma espécie de maldição
quando me pego eu me vejo nessa situação
obrigada a usar coisas que às vezes não
tenho escolha
eu tenho uma filha que hoje tem 17 anos
o nome dela gabriela ela é atriz
bailarina violinista e cantora ela tá
aqui é uma das criadoras desse projeto
chamado tá bom pra você
acontece que gabriela quando estava com
13 anos
ela leu um livro chamado um defeito de
cor que é um livro de ana maria
gonçalves uma escritora que eu gosto
muito é um romance que ela estava
fazendo um teatro e um dia para o flu
mãe eu tô fazendo teatro quer ser atriz
ou modelo
não sei cantar mas eu não vejo muito
espaço na publicidade nem no teatro no
cinema às vezes é um ou dois eu quero
falar sobre isso na verdade ela estava
um pouco revoltado né 13 anos a coisa é
um pouco complicada foi bom vamos botar
pra fora vamos fazer um blog falar sobre
isso e vamos ver no que dá
vamos propor esse debate logo depois
essa idéia virou um canal vão reproduzir
já que não tem é comerciais com a nossa
cara que represente a gente não vamos
reproduzir a província a gente consegue
provocar um pouco e fazer com que as
pessoas reflitam principalmente a
publicidade reflita sobre isso
a primeira ideia que eu tive foi falar
do padrão margarina
você já deve ter visto que os comerciais
de margarina são sempre a mesma coisa
casais héteros arianos ou minsk respeito
à moral os bons costumes com suas
esposas submissas recatadas e do lar
desculpa eu precisava falar isso tá
[Aplausos]
vocês já repararam que nesses comerciais
de margarina e outros tantos as mulheres
estão sempre felicíssimas por estarem
servindo todo mundo numa alegria eu não
sei que mulher acorda desse jeito mas
enfim
então nós criamos o primeiro comercial
protagonizado por uma família negra e no
canal tá bom pra você está disponível
o margarina black light ainda não está
nos supermercados mas nós eu continuamos
aguardando tá então pela primeira vez na
história no brasil
pelo menos nunca vi um comercial de
margarina com uma família negra
nós temos notado bom pra você e ali na
minha família
essa idéia partiu da gabriela com nos
questionamentos dela e falando comigo
mas logo depois a minha família toda
resolveu participar porque eu pressionei
não tinha escolha
e aí eu tinha em casa um ator que meu
marido que colabora muito com esse
projeto e meu filho que não é a thomas
resolveu colaborar
mesmo contrariado e eu queria falar que
esse padrão é muito perigoso porque ele
causa sérios problemas às pessoas que
não conseguem estar dentro desse padrão
problemas e até transtorno psicológico
como é o caso de juliette a juliet é
essa menina que é atormentada por esse
monstro chamado a lisandro a lisandro
carrega um pote eu vou contar direitinho
acontece que juliet é uma blogueira
muito famosa né feminista negra e tem o
cabelo assim parecido com o meu e que se
vê muito muito pressionada quando ela
tem que enfrentar sua primeira
entrevista de emprego a ela fica naquele
momento e ela começa
é o que acontece na sociedade vocês
devem ter visto que acontece com
mulheres negras que agora é ocupam
cargos que antes eram culpados só por
mulheres brancas atrizes cantoras né é
ataques racistas de é sempre acontecem
com essas mulheres gillette começa ver
se ficar um pouco pancada desesperada e
começa a ter alucinações e as t delírios
com lisandro que aparece com o pote
enorme de alisante e outros instrumentos
de tortura que nem que as pessoas que
têm o cabelo como eu não estou a fim de
usar então sequer aparece um pesadelo de
juliette na escola no computador
o negócio fica série ela vai parar num
hospício isso é sério é sério
a outra comercial que eu quis provocar
esse debate foi sobre uma coisa muito
simples que acontece com qualquer mulher
que a menstruação
só que não tem comercial absorvente com
a mulher negra
eu vi leilão gostar de uma importante
ativista negra falando isso eu acho que
essa entrevista já tenho 25 anos ela
falou nunca vi um comercial de
absorventes com mulher negra então nós
criamos o absorvente black livre
disponível também está bom pra você em
breve nos mercados
a gente continua também aguardando é e
aí eu queria falar de outros produtos
que a gente consome né
vale lembrar que nós negros são 57% da
população do brasil segundo o ibge
consumimos mais de um trilhão e meio de
reais por ano
mas na indústria da publicidade
audiovisual somos apenas 4% né
e nós consumimos esses produtos aqui tal
cereal black que também está no tá bom
pra você
né fizemos também o comercial de pasta
de dente creme dental total protection
black
fiquei por incrível que pareça a gente
escolhe os dentes né
o pior de tudo a gente compra esses
produtos vão pensar como eu falei eu vou
imaginar mas somos mais da metade da
população
imagina se a gente pára de comprar esses
produtos o que aconteceria a agora eu
quero falar da minha irmã beatriz
nascimento que infelizmente nos deixou
aos 17 anos
mas eu guardei todos os ensinamentos
dela
a minha irmã quando era nova nasceu no
subúrbio do rio de janeiro ela fez
questão de me levar
em lugares da é freqüentado pela elite
carioca e ela me levava nesses lugares e
olhava pra mim e falava olha eu estou
trazendo aqui é para você aprender que
ninguém ninguém tem o direito de dizer
que você não pode entrar nesses lugares
então isso eu aprendi direitinho e agora
quero mostrar para vocês o que acontece
quando crianças e jovens se sentem
representados
essas imagens que eu vou mostrar agora
são fotos de crianças que foram
fotografadas por seus pais quando se
sentiram representados eu acho que não
preciso nem comentar nada nela tem um
menino essa foto é um garoto dos estados
unidos a mãe fotografou quando viu a
reação do filho quando se identificou
com a criança que vinha no pacote de
fraldas a criança com a boneca eu acho
que não preciso comentar mas eu queria
comentar essa última foto desse menino
que hoje tem 20 anos é um estudante de
biomedicina ele é um menino negro
quando eu morei na venezuela trabalhava
com um ramo do esporte
meu filho uma vez chegou em casa
chorando pra caramba não conseguia falar
foi para o banheiro
queria falar comigo e o tentamos falar
com ele eu perguntei o que tinha que foi
ele falou mamãe eu entrei na escola e
todas as crianças riram e perguntaram se
alguém tinha esquecido no forno é isso
ainda é muito complicado então
[Música]
então eu falei o que eu faço
ele tinha 13 14 anos eu falei como é que
eu falo que a sociedade está doente que
ele não tem problema
peguei uma letra de uma música chamada
negro drama de manu brown
eu falei ouvir essa música uma duas três
vezes sozinho depois se você quiser a
gente conversa bate-papo ver o que você
achou disso e vamos conversar vamos
resolver essa história ele pegou adorou
depois desse dia a gente passou a ouvir
um cd dos racionais pelo menos dez vezes
por dia e o matheus que esse menino que
faz biomedicina é meu filho e aí quando
eu voltei para o brasil eu fiz questão
diga e fotografar a primeira reação dele
quando ele viu o ídolo dele é um ano
brown no palco e estava muito cheio
procurando queria tirar uma foto não via
ninguém daqui a pouco filho onde dias
passar aquela deus a maravilhosa que
estava aqui agora eu agarrei no brasil
foi por favor meu filho precisa conhecer
eu não conhecia ele na época meu filho
precisa conhecer uma bela flor não tá
entendeu a situação foi nossa preciso
levar esse menino
aí ele depois ele com seu ídolo bom que
eu quero dizer é que a
representatividade é importante sim
importantíssima para a sociedade e muito
boa para os negócios
né já que metade dessa população consome
todos os produtos é bom que a gente está
em são paulo para poder falar disso
nós não queremos ser iguais a ninguém
não é isso
é o que faz é interessante o que é mais
interessante no mundo é a diferença
não queremos direito não queremos ser
iguais ninguém mas merecemos direitos
iguais e vamos lutar por eles é certa eu
acho que é muito simples
não precisamos da simpatia de pessoas
contagiadas pelo comercial de margarina
que acha o máximo dizer não eu não sou
racista o meu melhor amigo é um negão
não não é por aí
é sempre é só entender que se tem uma
cadeira pra mim você tem que ter uma pra
mim também né
é isso nós estamos brigados mas estamos
falando de uma nação nós somos a nação
brasileira
aqui não é um clube de amigos onde entra
teus monta o título frio não nós todos
somos a humanidade devemos respeitar a
humanidade os direitos do ser humano é
mesmo o que eu acho eu acho a
diversidade mais interessante do que um
dos cheiros bonecas são os princípios
seus deuses rainhas e reis todos iguais
não eu quero poder de repente dá próxima
vez poder fechar os olhos e sugiro que
vocês façam isso também amanhã ou depois
hoje mais tarde e tente imaginar
perceber que a sua mente está livre para
teus sonhos que vocês quiserem
as imagens que quiser construir os
filmes que vocês quiserem e com isso diz
construir nossas mentes que estão
colonizadas para isso a gente precisa de
novas histórias e por último como eu
costumo dizer é o bom mesmo é quando eu
posso aprender com você o que você ainda
não sabe sobre mim tá bom pra você pegar
[Aplausos]